airlines are happy about the plunging
oil price it reduces their fuel costs
and freight companies are too they can
now transport goods cheaper across the
oceans chemical and pharmaceutical
companies are also seeing their
production costs fall as the oil price
slips two years ago a barrel of north
sea brent crude cost 120 dollars since
then the price has fallen by one-third
and global oil production continues
apace even though demand is not keeping
up because economic growth has slowed in
Europe and China meanwhile US production
is rising the country is fracking a lot
of shale oil but experts say another
factor is responsible for the most
recent drop in oil prices speculation
speculations and my DD thank you laters
our market participants who bet on
certain price movements today at the
moment they expect the demand for oil to
further decrease while the oil supply is
extremely high and that's what's mainly
driving the current drop in prices
saloon it is implies 45 and OPEC members
have introduced how much they're
drilling Saudi Arabia even plans to
increase production analysts believe
some OPEC nations are driving down
prices in a bid to make us fracking
unprofitable and Saudi Arabia is a vital
player on the market it's still the
world's biggest oil producer Russia
comes in second place with the u.s. in
third followed by China and Canada low
oil prices are already causing problems
for some countries especially for those
whose economies largely depend on oil
production one example is Venezuela it
needs an oil price of one hundred twenty
dollars to stay solvent Nigeria needs
oil to sell at 117 dollars or it faces
bankruptcy while Libya gets by if the
price is over 110 dollars in Russia less
than one hundred dollars a barrel spells
trouble and oil supplies are growing but
demand is falling
that's because cars are becoming more
fuel-efficient and renewable energy
supplies are grabbing a greater and
greater share of the energy market